john milton's paradise lost is regarded
by many as one of the greatest ever
poems written in the english language an
epic poem that follows two different
narratives the biblical story of adam
and eve as they fall from grace and are
expelled from the garden of eden and the
story of satan or lucifer who along with
the other fallen angels must create
their own home after being expelled from
heaven just for some overall context
john milton was an english poet born in
1608 he was a huge advocate for freedom
of speech and freedom of the press which
are aspects that certainly bleed into
his work milton was not a big fan of the
monarchy and many believe this is why
his portrayal of satan is much more
sympathetic it aims to tell you his
story as opposed to just telling you he
is evil
paradise loss was first published in
1667
and consisted of 10 books in 1674
it was redrafted to contain 12 books
john milton is considered amongst the
greatest english poets to have ever
lived and paradise lost was seen as his
magnus opus the greatest of all his work
now i know stories and poetry from
hundreds of years ago can be difficult
to read at times so hopefully today's
not so brief summary of john milton's
paradise lost is somewhat comprehensible
or at the very least entertaining
before we go any further a quick word
from today's sponsor babel the only
language learning platform or
application you'll ever need with summer
here and many of us planning trips away
learning the basics of languages and
being able to interact with people
abroad is always useful i began by using
babble on my pc but then switched over
to my phone as it's just much easier to
use on the go with babel you can learn
languages in all manner of ways and it
doesn't matter if you're a beginner or
an expert i personally stick to the 10
minute lessons as they're easy to fit in
throughout the day or whenever you have
free time babble also teaches you more
than just vocabulary you learn all sorts
of culture traditions and history last
time i chose spanish and continuing our
journey today's lesson is on pronouncing
double lettered words
egos
[Music]
as you can see i've clearly mastered
spanish so it won't be long before
mythology and fiction explain gets its
very own spanish channel just don't ask
me how to say that in spanish so if
you'd like to start learning a new
language then use my link in the
description to get 65 percent of your
subscription
[Music]
the poem begins with a brief discussion
of humankind and its disobedience
towards god this refers to adam and eve
eating the forbidden fruit from the tree
of knowledge milton's speaker places
some of the blame on the infernal
serpent the fallen angel that he refers
to as satan and some of us may know as
lucifer this angel stirred hatred envy
and revenge he placed himself above his
peers believing his glory to be equal to
god this turned into a war in heaven
which resulted in god hurling satan and
his followers from heaven into a fiery
pit below the fallen angels wake up in a
lake of fire in tartarus or what we know
as hell where they are bound by
adamantine chains
when satan wakes he describes his
surroundings
a dungeon horrible on all sides round as
one great furnace flamed yet from those
flames no light but rather darkness
visible for those rebellious hear their
prison ordained in utter darkness and
their portion set as far removed from
god and light of heaven
milton does a great job here contrasting
the two domains if heaven is a place in
the sky full of light then wherever
satan and the other fallen angels have
woken is a dungeon a fiery abyss where
only darkness is visible a prison for
the fallen
next to satan is his second-in-command
beaslebub despite the predicament they
find themselves in satan feels no regret
for his rebellion against god in fact he
sees this time as a period of regrouping
before they launch their next attack
beazlebub is not so convinced after
witnessing their failure the first time
he questions whether god can be defeated
satan doesn't dismiss this idea rather
than another battle head on he suggests
a new tactic
god has many beloved creatures and so
what if they were able to corrupt them
using their powers and the allure of
evil
to do ought good will never be our task
but ever to do ill our soul delight as
being contrary to his high will whom we
resist if then his providence out of our
evil seek to bring forth good our labor
must be to pervert to that end and out
of good to still find means of evil
rather than another battle in heaven
what satan is recommending is a proxy
war halfway in between heaven and hell
using god's favorite creations
now with a plan the two angels spread
their wings and leave this river of fire
many argue here that they did not break
free of their chains instead they were
allowed to leave because this was not
the punishment that god intended
flying above they scour the land and
come to the conclusion that it's better
to reign in hell than serve in heaven
once on land satan calls out to his
fellow fallen angels and beckons them to
his cause the speech had its desired
effects as the fallen angels were woken
from their slumber they gathered around
satan who informed them that they had
been erased from the book of life and
the other books in heaven but all was
not lost as even demons could be
worshiped like gods in the eyes of man
during this speech we learn the names of
a few more fallen angels turned demons
moloch the king of human sacrifice and
the lustful belial
by the end of this speech satan had
taken the thousands of wounded and
disheveled angels and turned them into
an army that once again believed in a
cause rather than be ashamed of their
actions they should instead embrace
their evil nature and be proud of the
demons they have become
they can make themselves a new home here
in hell and to mark this day they
construct a great temple in the city
known as pandemonium which in greek
means all the demons and all the spirits
in latin pandemonium became the focal
point where all the demons gathered for
council in the first gathering here
satan is honest with his peers the war
in heaven was difficult and it might
just be impossible for them to ever
retake heaven he opens the floor to
anyone who wants to speak
and upsteps monarch
molok favors the direct approach of open
war believing they should lay siege to
heaven once again but this time using
the new found weapons of hell molok is
driven by revenge and anger to him there
is nothing worse than their fate in hell
not even death and so there is nothing
to lose by striking now when those in
heaven least expect them to do so to him
there is no downside to this plan either
way they are free from hell
next to speak is a much calmer belial he
believes their punishment could be even
worse if they choose to attack heaven
again there might come a time where god
even forgives them for their betrayal
but belial doesn't necessarily advocate
for peace they should wait and see what
god has planned for them and then act
upon the matter
next step forward is mammon he doesn't
call for war either but also accepts
that he will never bow down to god again
mammon calls for industry they are free
to do as they please in hell if they
work together they can make hell a
kingdom as great as heaven this idea is
met by applause and garnered the most
support from his fellow demons so far
the last to speak is beaslebub who also
wishes to be free of god's servitude he
tells his peers of stories he heard in
heaven the creation of a new world that
would be populated by man a new race
that god loves even more than angels
they can have their revenge by
corrupting and destroying these humans
without another war
this suggestion garners even more
support than the idea put forward by
mammon when their votes are cast it is
the idea discussed by beaslebab and
satan that is chosen as their plan of
action
it is satan who volunteers to leave hell
and scout for this promised land with
satan gone the council reconvenes and
discusses how to begin building hell
into a kingdom that can rival heaven
satan now has the rather difficult task
of finding a way out of hell
eventually he reaches the gates of which
there are nine in total three made from
brass three from iron and lastly three
from adamantine guarding these gates he
sees two figures in the distance a woman
with the lower half of a serpent
surrounded by a pack of dogs and the
second is shrouded in darkness these two
figures are known as sin and death satan
confronts this woman and demands that he
is allowed to pass now this is where
things start to get strange
she asks him if he has forgotten who
they are she then explains that they are
his children sin and death
from his actions as an angel sin was
created springing forth from his head
she was then impregnated by satan giving
birth to death who then in turn
impregnated sin and this time she gave
birth to a pack of hounds that follow
and torment her
satan's children were responsible for
guarding the gates of hell as well as
the keys needed to open them
he soon realizes that his children can
be persuaded to join his cause after
explaining the plot for vengeance
against god his children as planned are
persuaded and sin using the keys unlocks
the gates of hell ahead of him is only
darkness but satan chooses to leave hell
and fly straight into the darkness
caught in a storm satan falls through
the sky until he catches a ride on a
cloud
flying blindly towards the noise he can
hear he finds himself in the presence of
chaos and night the rulers of this dark
abyss
i come no spy with purpose to explore or
to disturb the secrets of your realm
ensuring chaos and night that he means
no ill will he finds himself explaining
his plan once again and asking for
assistance to find this new world
by claiming this new world and
corrupting it with evil satan claims
that chaos can also reign here freely
which is enough to convince them to join
his cause chaos points to where a new
world has been created and satan assumes
that this must be the prophesized earth
created by god for mankind sin and death
follow slowly behind satan creating a
bridge from hell to this new world which
will allow the demons of hell to easily
travel back and forth between the two
in book three we shift perspective to
heaven where god has been watching
everything transpire he can see satan
traveling to earth and knows that this
will lead to the fall of man the free
will he gave to man is what will lead to
this corruption and downfall however it
is the free will to love that makes man
different from the angels and god's
other creations
back to satan who has now found earth
when he lands he sees an enormous gate
that has a stairway that he assumes
connects earth to heaven satan sees
god's creation in all its glory and
feels an overwhelming jealousy drawn in
by the sun he comes across an angel
standing on a hill that he recognizes as
archangel uriel satan takes the form of
a cherub and approaches uriel he lies to
uriel telling him he has just come down
from heaven curious about this new world
and its inhabitants uriel is unable to
see past satan's disguise and is
actually rather happy to see an angel
come down from heaven with an interest
in learning about this new world that
god has created he even makes the
mistake of showing him paradise where
adam and eve live satan thanks uriel for
sharing his knowledge and flies off into
the distance with the information he
came for
satan lands on mount nefertes as he
contemplates the task ahead of him
seeing the beauty of eden and paradise
reminds him of a time in heaven when he
still possessed his innocence he begins
to have an internal struggle and unknown
to him archangel uriel is watching this
unfold he questions whether he could
ever return to heaven if he was to
repent but he concludes it would never
be the same and he is now past the point
of redemption the only way forward for
him is to stick to the plan of spreading
evil and sin to this paradise
uriel notices multiple different facial
expressions and rapid change in demeanor
something you would never see from a
cherub as they are joyous beings now he
begins to suspect that this cherub was
actually someone trying to deceive him
he travels to heaven to inform the
archangel gabriel that one of the fallen
angels may have found eden together they
vow to find this impostor by morning
satan has essentially overcome his
doubts and decides to enter eden
standing tallest of all the trees is the
tree of life and next to it is the tree
of knowledge satan transforms himself
into a bird and perches on the branches
of the tree of knowledge looking down he
observes the many different animals
however his attention is drawn to two
creatures in particular that stand
upright on two legs filled with rage and
jealousy satan remembers why he came to
paradise
these two beings must be the new race
that was created in his fall
he watches adam and eve and overhears
their conversation adam is telling eve
that she must be obedient to god because
this paradise is only possible because
of him she shouldn't complain about the
work they have to do because it means
they can roam and freely explore this
paradise with only one rule never to eat
the forbidden fruit from the tree of
knowledge as night falls gabriel and the
other angels begin to search the garden
they find satan who has switched his
disguise from a bird to a toad and they
bring him before gabriel he immediately
sees through this disguise and
recognizes satan demanding to know what
business he has in the garden of eden
satan tells gabriel that he means no
harm and they have no reason to suspect
anything else gabriel once again is not
convinced not willing to deal with any
more of satan's lies he tells him that
he will send him back to hell if he does
not confess
all this threat succeeds in doing is
enraging satan to the point of a
physical confrontation
as both angels posture they are
interrupted by a pair of golden scales a
sign from heaven knowing his own
strength as well as gabriel's satan
interprets these scales as a sign he
cannot win this battle and so he decides
to flee
in book five we have an interaction
between adam and eve where she describes
a dream she had in this stream eve was
woken by voices that she could hear
coming from the tree of knowledge
following the whispers she then sees
what she believes is an angel eating
fruit from the tree the angel encourages
eve to taste for herself
here happy creature fair angelic eve
partake thou also
happy thou thou art
happier thou may be worthier canst not
be
taste this
and be henceforth among the gods thyself
a goddess
not to earth confined
the angel is trying to persuade eve by
insinuating she could become a goddess
by merely tasting the fruit before eve
is able to do so the angel disappears
and she wakes from her dream adam is
fairly concerned but does his best to
reassure eve that this was just a dream
and not an indication of the future
because eve just like adam has free will
the gifts given by god at this point god
is fully aware of satan's plan however
he still believes his human creation can
exercise their free will he sends for
the archangel raphael instructing him to
go to eden and explain why the fruit is
forbidden or at least explain the
differences between food that is
considered earthly and heavenly at least
then it has been explained to them when
satan comes both adam and eve know that
eating from the tree is forbidden if
they choose to exercise their free will
knowing this then their punishments are
their own raphael does explain these
differences to adam who in turn is
expected to relay this information to
eve when adam questions why any creature
of god would willingly disobey him
raphael tells him the story of satan and
his fall from grace as a cautionary tale
heaven was always a place of peace until
the day god announced he had created a
son that he wished to rule with him
one angel in particular took issue of
this and voiced his frustration and
anger that angel would be stripped of
his heavenly name and for his
disobedience he would be known as satan
as one of god's most loyal and trusted
angels satan believed he deserves to
rule alongside god and thus the
rebellion began satan convinced a third
of the angels to join his cause and
contest the rule in heaven a rebellious
angel by the name of abdiel eventually
saw the error of his ways and tried to
convince satan that this was not a
battle that could be won abdiel then
asked god for forgiveness which was
granted showing that for those who seek
it there will always be redemption this
discussion continues on into book six
where raphael discusses the war in
heaven in some more detail it ends with
raphael telling adam that satan and the
other fallen angels have already begun
plotting the fall of mankind he wishes
to lead adam and eve down the path of
sin they must be weary and fearful of
satan but they must also be brave enough
to resist him in book seven and eight
adam inquires about the creation of the
world and raphael agrees to explain
after the fall of satan and the other
rebellious angels god wished to fill
these absent places and so he found an
empty part of the universe devoid of
life and created the earth if mankind
showed obedience and belief in god's
will then there would be a day when the
earth and heaven become one this rather
long discussion ends with raphael
returning to heaven
in book nine we see satan's return to
the garden of eden avoiding the angels
who are watching the walls satan's
disguise of choice this time is a
serpent
when adam and eve wake up the next
morning they begin their workload
however with much to do eve suggests
that they perform separate tasks so they
could finish double the work in the same
amount of time reluctantly
agrees and they both go off in separate
directions when satan finds eve she's
alone which makes his plan much easier
to accomplish
the serpent calls out to eve and seduces
her claiming the fruit is what gave him
his intellect and the ability to speak
knowing the fruit is forbidden eve
attempts to resist however the serpent
continues to flatter her with
compliments of her beauty satan
continues by asking why would god forbid
the fruit unless it possessed some kind
of power that he wanted to keep for
himself
eve reached out and from the tree she
plucked an apple surely some fruits
couldn't do any harm adam's claims must
have been exaggerated
and so she took a bite of the apple
expecting to feel something wonderful
and she did feel invigorated at first
but soon this turned into a horrible
feeling the feeling of instant regret
not knowing what to do eve searched for
adam if she convinced him to also eat
the fruit then their sin would be equal
when she explained everything to adam
his choices were very simple if he
wished to remain with eve then he must
also consume the fruit to ensure they
suffer the same fate
and so adam also ate the fruit and just
like eve he felt its positive effects to
begin with the two end up having sex and
falling asleep under the tree when they
wake they are met with an overwhelming
guilt and shame it's clear to them that
they may have just lost their paradise
forever they cover their naked bodies in
leaves and it's not long before they
turn on each other blaming one another
for their fall from grace in book 10 the
angels return to heaven to inform god of
what has transpired in the garden but he
is fully aware having observed the
entire thing they try to share the blame
here as they failed to stop satan
entering the garden but god absolves
them of any guilt as he allowed this to
happen
he tells them that he will send his son
down to the earth to punish the sinners
when he arrives he asks adam and eve if
they ate from the tree adam admits that
he did after eve gave him the fruit and
eve tells him that she was tricked into
doing so by the serpent
punishing all three parties here the son
states that from now on serpents will be
cursed to forever crawl on their belly
never to rise
the children of adam will be forced to
labor all day and hunt for food the
children of eve will give birth in pain
and be forced to submit to their
husbands however the seed of eve will
take vengeance upon the serpent
satan begins his journey back to hell
victorious awaiting him are death and
sin
believing in their father they have
already finished creating the bridge
making the journey from hell to earth
much faster as satan leaves paradise his
children congratulate him on the
outskirts sin vows to corrupt the minds
of humankind and death will infect all
living things causing them to die
when satan returns to pandemonium he
calls out telling stories of his victory
however he does not receive the
reception he expected
no one is cheering the only thing he can
hear is the sound of hissing all of the
demons have been transformed into snakes
as punishment
hell is now full of trees containing
fruit whenever the snakes try to eat
from these trees the fruit turns to ash
meanwhile as promised to their father
sin and death arrive on the earth god
tells his angels that he will allow sin
and death to remain there until judgment
day where they must return to hell and
serve their eternal punishment with
their father
he also informs the angels the earth
will no longer be a perfect paradise
humans will now have to endure extreme
cold and blistering heat
animals begin to turn on each other and
some now even see adam and eve as food
in book 11 it is the archangel michael
who is given the task of expelling adam
and eve from eden although they can no
longer live in paradise if adam and eve
continue to live an honest and moral
life then upon death they will be
reunited with god in heaven
hearing their remorse god also decides
that his own son will be humanity's
biggest advocate and will end up paying
for their sins before michael expels
adam and eve from eden he shows adam the
future of humanity the events that will
transpire before the great flood in book
12 michael discusses the future of
mankind after the flood by the end of
this discussion adam is relieved to know
that despite these acts of sin there
will always be redemption
adam and eve are escorted from the gates
of paradise to this new world
knowing that paradise may have been lost
but hope still remained
[Music]
[Music]
you